c'est l'histoire d'un homme bleu qui
pousse une barrique bleus selon regard
d'une femme jaune et rouge qui a troqué
ses boucles d'oreilles pour une grappe
de raisin violée ça sent la fête a plané
du rhum et du vin tout le monde est
convié même les poissons ont rempli les
bouteilles et les vers la lune n'a qu'à
bien se tenir car ce soit elle ne sera
pas la seule à se fendre la gueule de
bois
les poissons représente dans tous ses
tableaux le mouvement collectif
le mouvement vers le moment de
convivialité l'une des choses qui nous
réunit dans ce pays c'est vraiment de la
convivialité dans les branches
évidemment c'est difficile lorsqu'il
s'agit pas le faire l'apologie de la
consommation d'alcool même temps ça fait
partie de notre culture des tableaux qui
ce fait la convivialité et qui raconte
aussi l'histoire de la martinique et de
ses différentes communautés
laurent valère célèbre à sa façon l'art
du vivre ensemble de côté à une
communauté noire de toute une communauté
blanche avec ses codes respectifs
agricole respectifs et au milieu il y a
le punch la la convivialité qui pourrait
qui nous invite à nous réunit gains
trouver des dénominateurs communs des
tableaux plus festif les uns que les
autres avec des couleurs chatoyantes ça
respire la joie et la gaieté grâce à la
technique à la matière choisi
l'acrylique et la résine des couleurs
assez facilement la clinique la collecte
permet et cette rapidité d'exécution
j'ai toujours peint avec cette technique
là et la rési nous permet d'avoir cet
aspect un peu glacé j'avais de dieu bien
glacé mais ce que je sais ce que ça veut
dire
et cette espèce de nasse fait un peu un
peu là qu'est un peu
brillant célébrer la convivialité c'est
bien mais attention à l'abus d'alcool
car ça peut vous faire dire n'importe où
j'appelle depuis 1848 eux va peut-être
falloir s'affranchir du rhum non